well i'll tell you what man i got bad
news for you here it is
humanity likely faces rapid catastrophic
collapse
study warns but you know what i'm not
going to read this article
you know why i don't want to read it
either we're not going to
because we've got something better to
talk about oh thank goodness
a new hope yeah elon musk oh yeah what
an
i i got a crush on him
i love it i i love scientists i love
astronauts i love
space and he he is like living the
american dream
he came here and is making
major waves on the space front and it's
amazing like we need that i'm
so psyched to have him in this country
doing what he's doing
that donald trump you know brought the
artemis program into
effect you know we're gonna go to the
moon you know
potentially in the next three years four
years it's like we're gonna go
to the moon we're planning on going to
mars like this is exciting this is such
an exciting time for
human life and this is it's awesome
there's a reason why i started this
segment
with a story saying we're facing
catastrophic disaster
because is a real reason that we need
the artemis project why we need people
like elon musk
and it's because if we are to survive we
need to look to the stars we need to
expand
and even outside of this idea of
colonizing other planets or expanding
space technology and development we we
this technology we develop for space
travel we use here on earth
yep which brings me to this story
oh yeah i i i highlight this as like the
silliest part of
like what i want to talk about with this
what the spacex the whole
dragon capsule working and and what it
means for america but go ahead
no no no this is hilarious though
a boat flying a trump flag approached
spacex's spaceship
after the astronauts landed nasa
promised to do a better job
next time i think they did a great job i
think it's great i think it's hilarious
it's perfect listen this guy with the
flag who showed up
whether you like trump or not that's
hope and that's optimism yeah it is
that's a dude rolling up to this spacex
thing and he's excited he's happy
you've got people who want to see this
they're cheering for spacex they're
having a good time
and that's the optimism i like to see
yeah it's it's i gotta tell you man i
have seen trump flags and banners and
stickers placed in the craziest places
oh yeah we talked about this where we
are there's like a weird lake
under a highway it's like not something
you go into it's gross
and somebody like somehow got out in the
middle of it and put the
trump flag the bear collar the bear
color
i don't know if you've seen this we
don't have it pulled up but there's like
uh you know one of those tracking
collars on a black bear
and someone somehow stuck a trump 2020
sticker on it
and there's a 5 000 cash reward it's
like the police are trying to figure out
who put it on there that's like somebody
who cares that's awesome that's brave
yeah
i think anything would eat you somebody
approached a black bear
yeah to put a trump 2020 sticker on the
collar i mean
i feel like there they earned it this is
not
this is not the important news if you
want to talk about
spacex yeah i mean we we
went back to space at under 2 million
per flight is insane compared to
the 30 40 million dollars of cost that
we were paying
russia to send our astronauts into space
so the fact that we can do it for
a pittance compared to what we were
spending now we can do it from american
soil
we can do it over and over again reusing
the rockets and that's why it costs so
cheap
this is this is the the first step in a
very new age of space travel and it's
incredible
so elon musk props to you you are you've
done an
amazing job of bringing uh bob and doug
back to the country
you know to earth to terra firma and
it's it's an incredible time to see that
this is
this stage now he's working on uh a
spaceship
that's one unit that will fly up and fly
around
and come back down to earth wow yeah i
mean he told you
you to your tweet you know what's up
yeah what's up with the iron man suit
elon and no i tweeted go ahead
hey elon musk why haven't you built an
iron man suit yet yeah and he said
working on starship
yep and i said that is an acceptable
response so he's doing it he's
there they're doing tests this week
about uh trying to figure out
to actually make that happen so so this
ship can launch
yep go into space and land back that's
the plan that seems insane to me that's
i
well i know but i got no but look have
you watched the
the falcon 9 of course of course that
was insane to me
that was cgi to me until i i saw it over
and over and over again and then i
i was watching it live and i'm like i
mean
this is the case it's landing itself
like
the dragon capsule flew itself docked
itself
it was fully autonomous we need
a better form of propulsion levitation
whatever
like what what's i think it's rad that
we're doing this yeah
but i'm curious if elon musk is is doing
research in other areas
come on of course he is i know yeah
you've got to think of the two companies
that
he's using spacex which is what we're
talking about
and then tesla which is an electric
powered
vehicle factory that he's he you know
and then you think about the
advancements of solar energy
batteries you know there's only a matter
of time before they figure out
some sort of new technology that gets us
into space without any sort of
propellant i got it
go ahead a really big magnet well i was
thinking this big slingshot
yeah really big or a little bit of both
actually have you seen the movie moon
no oh wait wait yeah maybe yeah uh i
mean it's kind of that was sam rockwell
yeah yeah awesome awesome movie yeah
good movie but there's a magnetic
slingshot actually and it's basically
just a mag system that shoots you
out into above orbit so you break orbit
yeah like a rail gun exactly a railgun
so that's that i think that's going to
be
kind of the future because if we set up
like a nice solid
railgun system i mean i think you need
to get to like 200 miles
so if we used magnets to propel us
and then with a little bit of a rocket
assistance you know to get
us the rest of the way i don't know yeah
you know i'm not a rocket scientist
so i'm just saying i think it's like the
the the size of a ship you need to carry
all the fuel
especially for a landing okay a full
vessel that to me sounds crazy
yeah but listen man politics still play
a huge role in this that's true
if we if we're being warned by the likes
of say greta tunberg
that the earth we have eight years left
or 12 years left i don't know what's
changing now we have a new study saying
the end is nigh
take a look at all the accounts on
twitter ragging on elon musk
where do they fall politically probably
on the left they definitely do and i
mean i see this whole thing about how
well elon musk praised china and it's
like
yeah because like they are trying to
push into space also they're trying to
you know push forward this their kids
the number one thing that they answered
on what
chinese children not political
the children of china that they haven't
done anything wrong yet
they want to be scientists that when
they grow up is that when was that from
that study
uh i don't know i read it i read it a
couple months ago so they want to be
older but they want to be astronauts
oh even better i know it's it's actually
more to your point okay we want to go to
space
right so that's and what do our what do
our kids want to do
they want to be youtubers no no no no no
they want to be influencers they want to
make duck face on instagram and tick
tock
okay that's another not disagreeing with
you right right
so it's like when you think about what
china
we got to remember that the ccp is is
not china as a whole like we gotta we
gotta let go of that because
the ccp is terrible they're they're
doing terrible things they're the
problem
they are absolutely the issue you know i
still feel for a lot of the chinese
citizens that have no choice in this
matter right now
think about the epic history of like
china before
the rise of mao and the communist party
yeah amazing yeah they've been
tainted by the evils of the ccp yep
that's a good point ism is nasty dude
yes it is
nasty stuff and that bums me out it bums
me out a lot
a lot a lot a lot of cool storied
history we you know
and it's and it's covered up now by
by communism yeah i mean i i want to go
i want to go visit china i want to go
visit russia i want to go visit
everywhere i want to go to egypt and i
and i think there's going to be amazing
people everywhere i go
because that's actually been the case
and i've traveled around the world
i've been to many many places and
there's awesome people everywhere
and there's not awesome people really
mad people
in most places too you know including
here i don't if you know elon musk
apparently what did he say like china is
awesome or something
yeah referencing their space programs
like that yeah probably because they're
you know well and you know they have a
billion people that
are probably buying a lot of teslas i
think that's the future of of
you know travel on this planet also i'm
i'm a bit tepid
you know i don't have really strong
words of criticism nor do i have strong
words of praise for his you know i can
criticize him for it but i can
understand
that there absolutely are you know parts
of china and things that the chinese
people do that are awesome that you can
be happy with
but i'm not i'm not gonna say i'm happy
with elon musk saying that especially as
wealthy as he is
well i don't i don't know the details i
don't know exactly what he's referring
to
he i i'm assuming because he sells
tesla's out there
and that you know he probably makes a
lot of money just like
well why is he why isn't anyone coming
down in the nba right now
but they're gonna we are sure we are but
they're gonna praise the nba when
they're doing
exactly it's political it's political i
don't period so so the reason why i say
i'm a bit tempted on it is
if there's something about like the hard
work of the you know chinese people
working towards space advancement
that's that's a fine thing but i would
lean negative if i knew if i
knew the fuller details i don't think we
should be at a point where we're
praising
what china as a whole is doing because
ccp runs everything they're doing well i
was like i wasn't texting i was not
praising
china at all yeah i know you am i so
this is
the title of this is elon musk bombshell
tech boss warns a complacent and
entitled us is losing to china and that
was the force of his message
he was talking about china being
efficient and effective and the us
just being entitled and there it is it's
like someone's been selling out our
country for the past
20 years it's china it's like the media
took him out of context when he
went when what the idea he was trying to
convey was they're doing a really good
job in these areas
and we're losing to them yep so saying
something like dude the u.s sucks when
it comes to space china's awesome it
gets better
oh yeah he goes the tech uh so somebody
asked him a question how about china as
an electric vehicle strategy leader in
the world
the tech mogul replied china rocks in my
opinion the energy in china is
great people there there's like a lot of
smart hard-working people so again he is
referring of course
people not the party there it is yup
that's exactly what i was thinking and
of course the people who are criticizing
him
are the ones who hate the fact that he's
going to bring us to space yep
dude it really does feel i'm sorry man i
i hate to go in this direction but
there's almost a good versus evil thing
going on that's exactly what it is
absolutely when you have somebody saying
i want to bring humanity to the stars
i want to help save us when our top
scientists say we must make it to mars
or other planets for humans to survive
and elon musk is like i'll do that
and then you have people that do
everything in their power to just hate
hate hate and tear him down i will
criticize the guy
he has got dumb tweets and he costs a
lot of people money when he tweets
stupid things about tesla stock for sure
there's the stupid thing he's about the
scuba diver the guy is far from perfect
but i'm going to give him credit on the
space flight stuff
true what are you going to get it's
crazy nuance doesn't exist to so many of
these people and that's why it really
does feel good versus evil
they want to know you keep saying it
feels that is literally what it is
it's good versus evil right now they
believe
that they are doing the the most
virtuous work
but in in the most evilist way yeah
i mean you saw that video of that uh i
don't know if he was
who he was if he was a trump supporter
or not but the infowars
girl was like let's go talk to the trump
supporters you know and they're like go
ahead set it up
this is a viral video and i you know
what
it could be that inforce is biased but i
i believe this because i've seen it
there's a black man and she's like let's
go to the trump supporters and tell them
you know we're liberals see what they
say
and all the trump supporters are hugging
the guy and shaking his hand like thank
you for coming here we're really glad
you're here this is great
people saying like it doesn't matter you
know black white we're all in this
together yep
one lady like gives him a hug and a kiss
on the cheek and he's like wow if i get
one more of those i'm coming in with
y'all and they're laughing having a good
time and then she's like let's go over
to the protest and tell them we're trump
supporters
yeah and everybody knows what happened i
don't need to i don't even if you
haven't seen the video i don't need to
tell you
well and if you haven't i mean i'll just
i'll go ahead and say it they start
they get swore at they're they're
telling them to that they're
white supremacists like all these crazy
things and
and the guy's face he's just like the
dudes just like what just happened did
that just happen
this is reality good versus evil i've
i've been to enough of these events
man i've seen it i've seen i was in san
i think it's san jose i think i was i'm
not sure
in california this mob of angry leftists
they were bernie supporters yeah
they shoved an elderly couple to the
ground ripped the trump hat off their
head and set it on fire
and they're like it's like an old out of
a slightly overweight out of shape
elderly couple knocked to the ground i'm
like what is happening these people are
nuts
and guess what happened this is when i
was at fusion at the time what happened
when i said these were bernie supporters
oh man they started getting angry how do
you know that and i was like they were
wearing bernie shirts
like well how do you know they weren't
faking it i was like one guy was yelling
bernie
one guy had a flag i was like what do
you want me to say man
these weren't hillary supporters running
around doing this it was bernie sanders
supporters
yep and they were like you're lying
temple's lying look at what they do to
andy no
yeah andy no he doesn't they say he
doxes people
he literally publishes the same
information as all the news outlets he
just puts it on twitter yeah so they
they target him they harass him they try
and you know
come after him so anyway we'll keep i
want to keep it back to the the science
stuff
the point the reason i bring this up is
we need
we need this we desperately need this we
need it we need we need technological
advancement
to better the lives of the poor they say
we need universal health care fantastic
you know the best way we can we
you know the best way to go about
getting there new medical technologies
reducing the cost of treatments reducing
the cost and you can't do these things
completely with policy trump just did an
executive order to reduce the cost
because yes there's exploitation
i hate it epipens they shouldn't cost
that much money
that's nuts yeah that's insane so trump
is like i'm gonna sign some stuff you
can do that but guess what you know what
else you could do
new ways of producing treatments new
treatments new technologies that will
reduce the cost for everything and mass
production
well it's not just that we even need to
do all this with science
we have to create a way that it is
exciting for children you know uh
make heroes out of astronauts and
scientists and
doctors and you know these these people
that are gonna
are the ones that are actually paving
the way to a future
that you know everyone who doesn't want
to live
with wealth you know with uh wealth and
you know living comfortably in your life
you know
so we have to unders we have to
understand the kids need to
glorify you know going to space
being excited about figuring out how to
figure out
new rocket propulsion you know ways that
we're going to get there
instead of them going i want to be an
influencer i want to be famous
i just want people to love me it's like
that's not going to get us to
it's not you know what i mean and then
that's the key
so not only do we need all these
programs that are great
like sure it's getting us there but if
we don't have like the backing of the
new generations that are excited about
it that wa
that have a passion in it then it's not
gonna go anywhere this is this is this
is the
this is the fear i have is that we've
been on a track
towards like we've been on the back end
of the bell curve for quite some time
america had its time it's it's lasted
longer than the average
empire whatever you want to call it and
now we have new generations of young
people who aren't aspiring to be
legends to be heroes to be astronauts
right
to be explorers and pioneers they just
want people to look at their face
yep i don't think it's the end i think
we've recognized this problem
and if we don't correct we're like our
plane's going down we can pull up
and we can reach new heights with that
dip as we go down we can go boom and
shoot even higher
like you ever played mario you know when
you're flying with mario you got to go
down and then up you go even higher
that's what we're doing so now that we
recognize the problem
we need to inspire young people and
that's one thing that elon musk does
for all his faults by all means
criticize the guy launching that hot you
know that hot rod red convertible tesla
in a space with a dude sitting in the
driver's seat that's that's nothing
compared to
watching him launch two actual people
into space i disagree okay i understand
what you're saying though
to an adult you look at that and you're
like wow man that's amazing
okay and the cool technology but you
when you look at kids who don't
understand
because they're born with it yeah they
they see this cool
convertible and it looks like a rock
star i see what you're saying yeah that
i think look you know so so tesla uh i'm
sorry uh
elon needed some kind of payload to
prove they could launch into space he
chose the tesla
and that created this pop culture moment
star man
yep it created a historical moment a pop
culture moment it caught the attention
of people
there's a lot of people who don't care
that he launched these dudes into space
at a ridiculously low cost with new tech
and and reuse the rockets even and
brought them back
yep so flat screen controls yeah it's
cool stuff
just big three big screens it's like if
you look at it it's like i'm looking
into the future
yeah that's the future wait no no that's
now
but check it out kids so you know kids
who are born today
have not lived without a touchscreen
phone you're right you know you if you
if you were born after 2007 they've
always had touch they've always existed
that's a good point i remember
the phone would ring and me my brother
my sister would run to try and answer it
first
yeah it was a phone mounted on the wall
with the cord with the cord and
everything it would be tangled and
exactly oh yeah it's like oh back in my
day we only had one phone on the wall
and guess what
i'd call my friend's house and i'd be
like is jason home and his mom would be
like no i don't know where he is and i
go
guess i'm not hanging out with jason
today yeah maybe i'll run into him at
the park
yeah if i get lucky and you go around
looking for where your friends might be
and then you finally find out like
it's like you went on a quest every day
it's another thing that kids are losing
too
because i would it was almost like
carmen san diego was like i go to one
house and last i saw him he was at this
house i go there
actually they went to you know 7-eleven
you finally find them you're like i did
it
solved the mystery of where my friends
are anyway the point is i think a lot of
kids
are born and they see the touchscreen
rocket you know screens and everything
and they're like i have one of those
yeah but then they see a convertible and
they're like whoa
space convertible yeah yeah it's like a
weird unique thing
yeah and it looks cool well and and the
fact that
you know you your prize at the end of
that quest
was hanging out with your actual friends
in real life
whereas nowadays you just facetime
somebody
hey cool all right all right i'll talk
to you later i gotta do this youtube
video thing i can't believe
that we haven't regulated social media
yet
i can't believe it either it's coming i
think it's coming soon
the first thing i would actually
recommend doing is section 230 reform
absolutely immediately followed by a
regulation that removes the counters
from social media websites like likes
likes shares followers friends etc
that counter is the manipulation that's
a good point it is
and twitter knows it this is what and
i'll i'll just call this my
opinions and assumptions based on
conversations and data to avoid legal
issues with
certain people that actually may or may
not run twitter can i say that
well not not in this context okay never
mind i've talked about it
i've talked to some people who have
insider knowledge
and the general consensus is twitter
knows
that what drives engagement what makes
people use the platform and makes them
worth money
is that count how many retweets did i
get how many likes how many followers
how many followers do i have
it's a it's a number it's a game to
people it's almost like
it's people earning points and so
they've gamified
hate twitter is a is a rage system where
people hate each other
and they and they and it generates as
much rage as possible and the more rage
you generate the more points you get and
it satisfies people in their minds
they're addicted to it
yeah get rid of those numbers all this
goes away
no one will know how many responses
they're getting there'll be no ratioing
they'll get rid of all of it but they
won't do it because it's the only reason
people like their platform
that's a good point yep so though we're
in trouble
in that regard but maybe
we'll see how this election plays out
yeah i hope it plays out well
trump 2020. you know what man if i end
up living in a van miller woods or
something down by the river
hunting rabbit and deer and cooking up
and farming i'm not going to be
miserable i'm going to enjoy it
it's like it reminds me it's like thanos
you know when he finally snaps away half
the universe and he gets to go farm and
just
pick weird little fruits there you go
man that can be you
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode